una jornada tensa en Ucrania este
domingo de New York Times informó sobre
los planes de una presunta evacuación en
la capital del país en caso de
presentarse una falla general en el
sistema eléctrico capitalino y otros
recursos claves para la vida de los
ciudadanos muy
robobots estamos haciendo todo lo
posible para que esto no suceda pero
seamos honestos nuestros enemigos están
haciendo todo lo posible para mantener a
la ciudad sin calefacción electricidad y
suministro de agua y en general quieren
que todos muramos esa es su tarea y lo
bien que resistiremos depende de lo bien
que estemos preparados para diferentes
escenarios la urbe de unos 3 millones de
habitantes se ve constantemente afectada
por los apagones provocados por los
bombardeos rusos a la infraestructura
eléctrica sin embargo el director del
departamento de seguridad municipal de
kiev afirmó que por el momento no
existen motivos para una movilización de
estas proporciones además de hacer un
llamado a evitar especulaciones al
respecto Mientras tanto Rusia aumenta
sus ataques en el este del país y las
tropas ucranianas se acercan a la
anexada gerson los bombardeos entre
ambos bandos no cesan
sucedió como siempre solo que esta vez
fue más fuerte estaba acostado revisando
mi teléfono luego hubo un fuerte golpe
una explosión y eso fue todo
el principio el saporiya el disparo de
dos misiles por parte de las fuerzas
invasoras dejaron Al menos una persona
fallecida mientras Kendo niess se
reportaron ataques por parte de kiev